hi I'm Nick Gillespie and this is mad
well choises asked a libertarian 2012
we're celebrating the paperback release
at the end of the month of the
Declaration of Independence it'll be out
with a new forward that covers Occupy
Wall Street and a bunch of other stuff
that's happened in the past year since
the hardcover publication our next
question comes from Hobbs the tiger via
Twitter so how do we argue with our
earnest righty friends without them
screaming at us he's referring back to
an earlier question about how do we
argue with lefty friends matt how do we
argue with right I think kind of the
same way and understanding that they too
want presumably good things to happen to
the country into the world at large and
then we might have different arguments
about how to get there a lot of people
on the right tend to look at
libertarians as you know those who are
constantly changing the subject to pcp
legalization which is how jonah goldberg
wants put it to me nick and i had an
interesting conversation here with
Senator Jim DeMint from South Carolina
recently and I think once Republicans
realize that libertarians are much more
serious about fiscal conservatism than
the standard issue Republican and once
they foreground that issue once that
becomes the single most important issue
which I argue that it is at this point
the fact that we are careening towards a
budget paka lips right now libertarians
are the ones who are doing spade work on
this and talking about this insistently
once you show those bona fides those who
are interested in that are going to want
to have a conversation with you and they
could be Republicans or they could be
Democratic Governors like Andrew Cuomo
in New York so again look speaking the
same same language in terms of what you
want to accomplish recognize that you're
going to disagree about various things
and don't necessarily write off entire
swaths of people just because they have
different aesthetic taste than you uh
yeah no that's true i mean i think a lot
of politics get mixed up in aesthetics
and taste preferences rather than you
know fundamental goals and aspirations
but with right-wingers i always find one
of the real sticking points beyond what
Matt's talking about is the idea that
you know libertarians you know are just
pacifists are going to give up
you know take whatever invading horde
from you know from either Europe Asia
and arctica wants to take over a serious
question is you know to look at the
contradictions within right-wing
tendencies right-wingers will tell you
all the time that government is
incompetent by by definition it stinks
but we got to keep shoveling more money
in defense you know that kind of obvious
contradiction really needs to be called
that and kind of work through not a
nasty way but in a persistent way and
persistently we are here doing ask a
libertarian all day stay tuned in this
space and keep sending us questions